[Music]
matt is with us in new york city hey
matt how are you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
nothing much so i have a uh you know a
couple questions regarding my finances
so i'm 22 years old i'm currently
serving in the united states air force
in the air national guard
and i'm about 6 000
right now in debt
i'm looking to
move out of my parents house who i'm
currently living with right now looking
to move out of their house in about two
to uh you know three to four years and
get my own place down in florida
but i do not have any sort of uh
discipline whatsoever when it comes to
saving money and budgeting okay hard
stop hard stop oh i gotta catch up here
you're in the
army national guard did you say
air uh air national guard international
guard okay and you're how old
i'm 22. and that's a part-time gig or a
full-time gig
that's a part-time gig okay what do you
what's your full-time job
yes sir what is your full-time job
i'm a
private investigator
okay
and your
the national guard is typically done
state by state is it not can you
transfer to florida
yes i can
okay
but you went through a boot camp a
regiment to to join right
yes sir
and they taught you
discipline right
um sort of we were
i
went to boot camp um amidst this covet
um so it was it was really um
you know sort of short-handed with the
boot camps and discipline and what they
can do and what they can't do
and everything like that
the shorter version so what do you make
as a private investigator
your phone is screwed up you need to
speak directly into it
can you hear me yes sir that's better
thank you
thank you uh so i work about 50 50 to 55
hours weekly
the pay is 18.50 an hour
and so why does it take three years to
move to florida
just say just saving up money um you
know you make plenty of money you must
be partying your butt off yeah matt
where's the money going currently do you
know
i
really have no uh really have no save
with that i really don't i really don't
know
i think it's i think it's more so my
problem of going out during the week and
not budgeting and not saving my life
yeah every night yeah
well it sounds like there's your problem
and there's your solution i think we
need to stop going out and start getting
on a budget making a plan having a goal
set in front of us which you told me
your goal is to move out so i'm going to
use that to fuel my savings habits and
go you know what i'm going to cook at
home and if they want to hang out they
can come to my place i'll go to their
place we're going to do this on the
cheap because i got goals i'm gonna get
out of this six thousand dollars in debt
i'm gonna have an emergency fund so i
don't have to worry about
you know getting that next paycheck if
it doesn't show up and then we're gonna
go about the business of saving up to
get out of that house and i don't think
you need to be buying a house right now
go rent somewhere even if you move to
florida for a while yeah
i mean i i think you could be debt-free
move out everything within just a few
months here
but you're gonna have to really make
every dollar that you have behave
and so here's a rule i always use matt
um
you can't out earn your stupidity i
tried
you can't make enough to not know where
the money's going
no one can make that much that's how
people make 10 million dollars as an
athlete look up a few years later and
they're broke because they have no idea
and they say the same thing you said the
same thing i used to say i don't know
where i went
i don't know where i went
and so you don't want to wake up that
way at 30 years old man you're calling
it 22. the great news is you're only 22
and so it's time to get with it um time
to throw your shoulders back
and be a grown-up and stuff
and uh that means you're going to tell
you i want you to pretend like you're
managing this money
for someone else and it's your job
to manage the money well
and if you don't manage the money well
you're going to get fired
because you suck at your job
pretend that
and that helped me because as a as a
christian i started going this isn't my
money it's god's
and i suck at managing god's money and
then i want him to give me more
to which he laughs and says no
[Music]
you suck at handling my money
it's in the bible i like picturing it
yeah is that second opinions that's
where that one came from no it's in the
parable of the talents actually
but yeah yeah when you when you don't
manage well he not only doesn't give you
more he takes it from you and gives it
to the one who does manage well it's in
the bible and so yeah
and that that's the thing you always
tell audiences uh
matt and i'll tell you
pretend like you were managing money for
a company called you incorporated and
your job was to manage money for you
incorporated
that's your job now be good at your job
as soon as you do that you're gonna find
you've got money everywhere
and you're gonna be looking at your
party bubbas and saying nope nope nope
nope nope
22. there's lots of bigger goals than
drinking beer all night got bigger goals
smoking dope all night i got bigger
goals in this we've got stuff to do here
we're going to uh like be a grown-up pal
for that move out of the house go to
florida
got bigger goals you want to live a
grown-up life you got to do grown-up
stuff and you know i mean i mean
62-year-old children
and i meet 22-year-old grown-ups
so it's not an age thing it's just a
matter of
the one definition of maturity is
learning to delay pleasure for a greater
good
and so am i willing to pay a price for
something better am i willing no
discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
the way we say it around here is
that way and we also say
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else
but that requires having a vision for
your life there you go where there is no
vision that people perish and so you've
got to have those goals in front of you
or else you won't have any real reason
to manage your money well
honestly it is easier to overeat over
drink and be broke
except for the part when you wake up
it's fun for a little and you're fat and
hungover and broke i mean you know it's
a problem
and so you know it's easier in the
moment
you know but but it's easier in the long
term because here's the thing a guy i
used to work for you should tell me this
all the time he said you're going to pay
a price
you're either going to pay a price now
so you win
or you're going to pay the price of not
having paid a price and live a life of
mediocrity
and the life of mediocrity is the price
you pay
for being a half-butt
and he would look at me and go dave
don't be a half-butt
which i never really figured out exactly
what a half-butt is but i just didn't
want to is full butt the goal then i
well it's apparently i am but there you
go
shut up george